die reichsten schweizer nur ein prozent
der bevölkerung besitzen knapp die
hälfte des vermögens aller schweizer
zusammen die chance dass an akademiker
kind eine hochschule besucht ist in der
schweiz 1,5 mal höher als die eines
nichtakademiker kindes frauen verdienen
in der schweiz für den gleichen job im
schnitt 20 prozent weniger als männer
ist das gerecht wie müsste eine welt
beschaffen sein in der echte
gerechtigkeit herrscht stell dir vor du
kannst gemeinsam mit anderen festlegen
wie eine gerechte gesellschaft
auszusehen hat welche güter verteilt er
wie wer hat welche rechte wer krieg den
spitzen job.de nur einer haben kann
was ist ein gerechter lohn
hier diskutiert und diskutiert und
entwirft die gerechte welt damit eure
entscheide nicht parteiisch ausfallen
und ihr nicht einen star zu euren
gunsten entwerft wird euch ein schleier
des nichtwissens umgebunden hinter dem
schleier wisst ihr nicht werde ich in
dieser welt eine frau sein oder ein mann
werde ich in einer wohlsituierten
akademikerfamilie aufwachsen oder als
kind einer mittellosen migrantenfamilie
lebe ich in der stadt oder auf dem land
ohne oder mit kindern bin ich sportlich
oder eher nicht religiös oder
atheistisch keine ahnung
ihr macht die spielregeln ist aber nicht
an welcher position er später spielen
werdet in diesem urzustand werdet ihr
euch auf wenige prinzipien einigen die
eine gerechte gesellschaft ausmachen
das meint john rawls der erfinder dieses
gedankenexperiment er glaubt ihr
entscheidet euch hinter dem schleier des
nichtwissens für eine gesellschaft in
der es den am schlechtesten gestellten
möglichst gut geht denn ihr könntet ja
in dieser position sein
dieses sogenannte differenz prinzip
behauptet selbst ungleichheiten können
gerecht sein nämlich dann wenn sie
denjenigen zugute kommen die am
wenigsten haben
das heißt der ceo eine grossbank darf
sich ohne schlechtes gewissen einen
exorbitanten lohn auszahlen wenn auch
der angestellte am bankschalter mehr
verdient
gegen ungleichheit kann man nichts sagen
solange alle davon profitieren
stimmt das was ist gerecht